all right jasmine yes jasmine where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally texas
coast texas where's that
it's outside of beaumont
uh 91 miles from houston
and tell me about your family growing up
well
i have
three sisters
i have two brothers
one got killed over a dollar
in the state of texas
they were shooting pool and he shot my
brother with a shotgun
my mom was a registered nurse
and i was raised by my grandmama part my
grandmama and my mother
my mother came out here in california in
75
and we stayed in oakland california
and
when i was
five or six i remember i needed to go to
a special education class
because i couldn't read and write today
i still can't read and write but i can
read the bible and i won't miss a word
in the bible but if you give me an
application i can't read read it i can't
fill it out
now i've been on skid row
for
28 years
i've been back and forth to the
penitentiary
i had four numbers
and
i've been out of the penitentiary for
like
14 years
i was hardheaded
rebellious
i didn't i didn't like my family very
well and they didn't like me because i
became
a crack cocaine
i've been on crack cocaine for a long
period of time
i'll get off and i get back on
it's very much like
too much of an addiction when did you
start
i started when i was probably about 15
years old
and
i started snorting at first
smoking and we they call it a primo
back then
and it stopped working for me so i went
a little bit further and put it on crack
coat i tried crack okay
and
i've been only for like
40 years
in and out
my
cousin
used to play with me all the time
and
i'm talking about sexual advice
at that time i didn't i wasn't having
sex
but my mom she used to whoop me all the
time because i couldn't really write
and
i became real real
rebellious against her
because
my sister she would tell my mom oh she
doing this she doing that and my mom
would hurt me
til one day i got tired of me and i was
gonna bite her
but i caught myself
and
she put me up
and i went i never went back
but i'm on skid row but i have my own
apartment now
and i take good care of myself and i
didn't let her hold me back
because she didn't like me and i didn't
like her
i stole from my mom i stole from my
family i did all sorts of things then i
started prostituting
i had
syphilis
i had gonorrhea
i had a multiple of things because i was
just out there no place to go
i came out here to go to safe harbor
program in 2001
i got caught with two ounces of dope
and about 50 rocks in my bottle in my
crack bottle
and
i still sell
only by the grace of god i haven't went
back to prison yet
but it's hard out here
it's people getting killed off of
vietnam i thank god that i haven't been
killed or
hurt or harmed but i've been raped three
times
and
people don't know
how we live down here it's real hard for
us
even though people come down here to
feed us and stuff like that
it's complicated being down here if you
don't know what you're doing and you
don't know how to do it to survive
in a way you can survive skid row it's
horrible
to see the people out on the streets
laying on concrete
we are killing each other
it's really hard for me
because
i started being rebellious at the age of
11.
i would sneak away from my mouth
and smoke crap
when i first got raped
it was horrible
they took me to a cornfield
as fresno
i ran for my mom and i moved to fresno
i didn't know nothing about friends no
i just know i wanted to go
so i
moved to france now
i got paid
sometimes i can't sleep at night
then when i start prostituting in fresno
i got to get
i ran
i ran to bakersfield
i'm a runner
every time i get hurt i run
i was married at the age of 18 because
my mom made me marry stanley williams
and because i was pregnant
my first baby her name is star
and i got seven kids i got five girls
and two boys i smoked crack cocaine with
all them
thank god the guy had his hands on him
but
my son they had to put him on cell quilt
because
he needed to slow
down he was
hyper all the time
my daughter got i raised my daughter
until she was three years old
and i left her on the stairs of my
sister's house because i was going to
pill in a post
they had nowhere to take her
so i gave her to my sister
after that they started taking my babies
out my arm
i have a baby my mom
would make arrangement for somebody to
come get my baby which was my sister
she's older than me her name grandma
george
thomas prasad
i thank god today that she took my
babies
because i don't know they would be in
the system
they was in the system but my sister
came and got him she don't have miracle
but the rest of them is together thank
god
it's a hurting thing to get a baby
taking out your hand and you have to
walk away as a mother
so i relapse
start smoking all over again
seemed like i never stopped
because you have to stay up sometimes
when you're outside
when you're in a tent
and stayed in the tent 14 years of my
life
i've been on skid row now for like
32 years
and it's not easy
but i do
it's a lot of things
that i could tell you about my life
i used to be a lifeguard at diamond
porquette okay
i started doing that and became a maid
at a hotel
i quit that
then i moved to pomona
for a little while
i went to
prototypes at pomona
and
they helped me a lot
it's a good program
i got tired of doing the program i
started doing me again
so when i started doing me again
i relapsed
i started stealing cars
i started selling drugs
i stole my boyfriend truck i sold it
i saw the diamond ring that was on my
finger that he bought
i walked over dead bodies
and dropping
downtown like skid row
they just passing out on vietnam
thank god that i never touched vietnam
you cannot mix it all with anything
as a kid
so
my best friend
she died
on vietnam
she took a lot of fentanyl and killed
herself
she od the woman who helped me deliver
my baby in the tent her name my baby
name is miracle i named a miracle
i had in the tent on gladys
downtown
before the ambulance got here she was
out
because
the water bag had busted like
hours
before she came and i was just walking
around in pain
still he wanted to chase that crack
cocaine
today
i'm still on crack cocaine
but i'm more responsible for myself
i don't stay in the team
i stand
in a con in the condo
one bedroom house
so
i tell you it's not easy
this life that i had i drug myself
through the mud
and i'm still smoking tell me a little
bit more about your childhood
my childhood was your dad in your life
somewhat
he used to hit my mom
until my mom got tired of it and took
her took us all to california we moved
away from him
he used to beat on my mom all the time
and my mom got tired tired she'd go to
work and come home
he'll go to work and come home but he
was an alcoholic
so
i went to school
and my
teacher miss pickett never forget it
she loved me like i was her own child
she took me to her house
let me ride on her horse let me play in
her pun we got in the pond and we swim
together
she was a nice she was a white girl but
she
really sweet to me
and she asked my mama one day can she
have me because she couldn't have babies
my mom told her no you can't have my
child
i didn't see miss pickett no more
because my mom took us to california
but i loved her so much and i wish my
mom would have gave it to me because i
got tired of the whoopies that she was
giving me
she abused me
and i didn't like it so when i moved to
california
i moved here when i was nine years old
when i moved to california
you couldn't whoop your kids
i was so happy but she did it anyway
because i wouldn't go to school i went
to attenuation school i had blew all the
other schools out
and i went to attenuation school
i started skipping classes and getting
high
doing doing what i do
my mom took time out with me
and
i got in trouble for it
but i just didn't want to go to school i
don't have education
and
i just basically just do what i do and
now i'm on since i
and
i get food stamps
i don't waste my money on crack
i
sell
the crack that i get
told to have extra money to buy me
panties bras
little nice things
and i sell the crack before i can have
nice things i can have some food in my
house because sometimes i don't get
enough footsteps
i have a roommate
his name is rayford and he's very sweet
he's way older than me he's 63 years old
so he told me he's going to teach me how
to read i said no you're not because i
don't want to know
because i'm so i'm embarrassed of it
because i never got a chance to read a
book
first book i ever read was the bible and
i was in the penitentiary in dallas
texas
on a grapevine
i got out of dallas texas
i did nine months because in dallas
texas they don't get i had 10 years they
don't give you
years they give you months on a year
so
after that i went to
i came out to california
i came to um
my mom moved us to california and then i
really started acting up because i knew
she couldn't whoop me
but she did it
and
i'm i'm a child that rebels against
everything that i think that's wrong
that it has to do with me
even if it's not wrong i didn't like it
i wouldn't listen i was just hardheaded
so
one day i decided to cut my sides off
and they never grew back
i have lupus
my mom don't know
i have lupus and
i have arthritis in my legs
so sometimes my legs hurt where i can't
go to sleep at night
so i stay up and my medicine is the
cocaine because nothing else works
i don't want to get addicted to pills
they put me on oxycontin and i wouldn't
take them i sold them
i saw them for like i got
45 blues and i sold them for like 1500
i still i got worship and worship on the
crack okay
when i get up in the morning i'll eat
and then i'll smoke some crack because
it eases my legs
i can't stand up
a period of time
when i was
14 i did gymnastics
i just seen
i'm too heavy to
do gymnastics
and when i worry a lot
my body reacts different i get sick
from the lupus
it's a trait of cancer
i don't know when god's gonna take me
it's scary it's very very scary
and it's hurtful
because my mom don't know nobody don't
know they don't they don't know where
i'm at nothing because i don't want them
to know
my family really hurt me a lot
like my sister she just took my kids for
me
and she won't let me see him
she took they grown so
my son don't want to see me
because i left him
that's some of the reason why i smoke
cocaine to take away the bag
it's not easy for me to be standing here
talking to you guys right now
it's a hurtful thing
it's a hurtful thing when your mom
rejects you
and she let the other daughter better
than you she loved me
cause she used to give gwen everything
because she was smart she could read
right
i couldn't
i got a blockage now
my teacher called it
she called it something i don't remember
i could count
but
tell you a bit some things that you
could never imagine
being on skid row i don't slept on the
sidewalk
no blanket
i don't have my period no tampons
it's horrible
to tell you all these things that i've
been
one day i took a lady's sheet
put it between my legs to have my period
that's because i didn't have a
mother she was like far far away from me
i wouldn't do nothing she told me to do
go to school
you better bring home a good report card
i had all efforts
and she woke me one day
and i hated it
i hated it i called it abuse
i never put my kids
when i had my daughter i never walked
there i put her in the corner told her
time out
because i've been through it
my dad left us
us
and married another woman
didn't leave us nothing
and he had a good job
he didn't leave us anything
my mom was our mama and our daddy
so she was kind of frustrated too
it's hard
telling others because
i think about it every day
it's past
and i still hold on to it
my son is sitting on army
and i tried to contact him
and he told his sergeant
he didn't want to talk to me
so
i tried to look my kids up the only one
talk to me is my oldest daughter
star
[Music]
it's real hard for me right now
jasmine do you feel like crack cocaine
kind of destroyed your life
this drug
my kids
take it from me
my
four bedroom
apartment i lost that i was in oakland
and um
my daughter miracle
she was so pretty she had real real
thick hair and jet black i mean she was
so black she was purple
but
the thing is
she got blue eyes
like the sky
i haven't seen it since i haven't seen
it since she was two months old
the lady used to bring her to jail and
and let me see her
he was trying to get her back to me but
i read and left her
i don't know what she had we can't find
her my sister said she looked for her
because she put all the kids together
thank god they grown they got jobs
they're smart they can read and write
and nothing like me
but they look like me
so
that's the end of my story
all right jasmine thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome
how old are you
i'm 57
she's got plenty of time
i wish you lots of luck
thank you thank you
you